on va voir qui connaît le mieux tpm paix
entre big flo et oli et les chroniqueurs
de tpm pays alors attention
big flo et oli duras big flo et oli où
les chroniqueurs de tpm pay attention
big flo et oli et il veut jouer aussi
fabien jonquois jouer quels invités qui
est venu le plus souvent dans tpm p
kelly malik bentalha ben ali ben talha
vous vous dites quoi je dirais que gad
elmaleh est de manille mettez vous
d'accord d'humoristes c'est sur une
balle à bentalha donc comme kelly n'est
pas comme kelly diane un truc qui vous
étiez margalit équipes à égalité ouais
ça a dit un autre huit mois j'ai vegan
garder le match ghana eh bien je vais
vous dire en troisième position c'est
malik bentalha en deuxième position
c'est karine lemarchand franck dubosc et
stéphane rotenberg est l'invité qui est
venu le plus dans tp mpc kev adams c'est
toi il est venu cesse pour fergie
attention quelques chroniqueurs un
talents de ventriloque
on avait fait un jour dans l'ordre
incroyable talent oui bah moi c'est pas
bon c'était pas jean-luc lemoine
non jean michel maire non mais bon j'ai
l'impression que personne ne connaissait
pas mais là c'est loin de toi mais c'est
d'ailleurs c'était benjamin castaldi
dans l'émission les chroniqueurs ont un
incroyable mais lui sait pas ou pas et
comment il peut pas être cours en syrie
mais ils se voient même pas lui même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça va castaldi et son numéro de
ventriloquie
[Applaudissements]
comment tu t'appelles même le cadreur
regarder attention les cherry pour
l'instant il ya zéro point par contre ça
va chauffer sur s'adapte sourire qu'elle
chante revenant dans le queens avec le
roi parce que là je vois que ça prend
pas cette belle chanteuse
j'ai accueilli sur le plateau en ayant
10 5 minutes avant nicole cesse merci
canal
comment dix ans j'avais été cueillis sur
le plateau
c'est quoi cette merde
ça
[Applaudissements]
et c'est que cette merde la caisse car
mettez moi quelque chose d'ouvert
c'était quoi ça tient au plan régie par
les et nicole si ça assez les pussycat
dolls vettel ou des toits qu'on connaît
et à l'école scherzinger qui l'aura le
voir tout
et
[Applaudissements]
cette chanson chanson j'en rigolais
j'adore tout tu me connais toutes les
paroles je compatis parce que ça m'est
arrivé ajoute aussi mais j'étais dans un
mba à paris et le mec m'a pas reconnue
c'est souvent mon frère quand on connaît
le plus j'étais comme ça avec une
capuche et il y avait un sens qui
passait dans une radio contenu qui passe
du rap
ouais j'ai dit c'est vraiment de la
merde me fluo n'en arrête c'est comme ça
dit tout a dit gérard midi c'était comme
ça pas bien tu veux je dise quoi c'est
moi alors je vous l'écrivais anecdotes
commença par cyril agence à paris